Om man vänder på det då, vilken doft uppskattar män?
Jag köper ju mango-passion på sådana här stort flaskor, jag vet inte.
Är det en klassisk mansdoft då som män gillar?
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju Chernobyl-generationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har renlös bra ord.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi gästen Tom Flemer till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Tjena Tom!
Tjena, tack så mycket, kul att vara här.
Jag ska säga redan i uppstarten här att det här är lite annorlunda upplägg än vanligt.
För att jag hörde av mig till dig på LinkedIn och bara skrev att tja, jag håller inte med dig om sådär jättemycket.
Kan inte vi bara snacka om dig i podden?
Du hoppade bara på direkt.
Det var ingen känsligt där.
Nej, det är kul att vara här.
Jag har lyssnat på några avsnitt nu och tycker du gör det superbra.
Folk är så rädda om att man tycker olika.
Jag fattar inte den grejen.
Det är det som är härligt med ett samtal, att man kan diskutera, ska vara högt i tak.
Så i alla fall, jag lagde.
Jag håller med och jag kan också tycka att det är på något sätt då man faktiskt lär sig någonting.
Eller man får någon sorts insikt när man vågar ifrågasätta ett argument.
Eller att, varför gör du så där?
Jag gör så på grund av, jag köper inte den.
Jag lärde mig detta när jag var...
Och så får man argumentet lite djupare än att det bara blir på den ytliga Twitter-nivån där.
Jag ska missförstå allting du säger och så ska jag lägga in någon grej som inte alls har med det att göra.
Ja, det finns ju någon typ av konsensus sjuka i Sverige.
Där målet är att vi ska tycka precis likadant.
Har vi gjort det, då har vi löst problemet.
Tycker alla samma saker, har alla samma idé om lösning på problem.
Då är uppgiften löst, ungefär.
Och så är det ju inte i verkligheten och så är det verkligen inte entreprenörskap.
Där det verkligen handlar om att våga tänka mot praxis.
Vad som är bekräftade sanningar i en bransch eller när det kommer till hur man gör affärer.
Och det där tycker jag är märkligt att det är ibland just i medeklimatet, just i branschen jag är verksam i.
Så det är väldigt många som springer åt samma håll.
Och det dråder trender, det kommer vissa sanningar, det är vissa sanningssägare därute som...
Lägger ut texten och beskriver, det här är det som gäller just nu.
Och sen så köper folk på det och så bara, ja men så är det.
Och så springer man på.
Och det tror jag, man behöver nyktera till lite.
Och det tycker jag är kul att diskutera.
Och med det sagt, ja, allt jag säger är ju inte 100% sanning.
Jag sitter inte på facit.
Men jag tror att väldigt ofta så glömmer man att vända på perspektiven.
Det är nyttigt att ifrågasätta saker och diskutera det.
Inte för att det behöva fel i sak, men man måste kunna diskutera saker, kunna prata om det och vrida och vända på det.
För ingenting är svart eller vitt, utan man kommer ju närmare sanningen om man håller på och bollar lite.
Om det nu finns en sanning, jag tror att det finns många stigare upp för berget så att säga.
Ja, men jag håller med.
Kan du inte ge...
Du har ju blivit lite halvmedial här, framförallt med några break-it-artiklar och du var även med i The Apprentice som du vann.
Du hade en podd som, som man väl verkligen får säga, blev betydligt större än vad varumärket var på den tiden.
Så du har ju blivit halvmedial, men då har man ju egentligen bara fått höra Moss & Noor, alltså det här hudvårdsbrandet.
Men du har ju en verklighet innan det.
Du startade ju inte det företaget när du var 18-bast, utan du har ju en bakgrund inom någonting.
Kan du inte bara ge oss den bakgrunden så att man får lite förståelse för din bana?
Det är inte 20 minuters biografi, men bara i bakgrunden.
Nu kommer jag med hela mitt CV.
Exakt.
Det är relevant ändå.
Man kan säga att min resa började med att jag skulle bli bäst i världen på simning.
Jag kommer från en familj med stor idrottsbakgrund, så för mig var det aldrig skolan en prio.
Det uppmuntrades väl hemma, men det fanns liksom inget akademiskt att ärva ner.
Det fanns massa tränings-
och idrotts-DNA att ärva.
Så jag födde Stockholm i Vasastan.
Bot här nästan hela mitt liv.
Vart iväg lite i London och Malmö och Oslo.
Men nu tillbaka.
Jag bor i Stockholm.
39 år gammal.
Jag fann simningen tidigt.
Är simmare en egensinnig människo?
Man ligger ju mest och bara tittar ner i en bassäng.
Ni lyssnar väl inte ens i hörlurar, utan man bara simmar där i tystnad.
Vissa gör det nu.
Vissa har börjat simma med AirPods.
Det var någon här i OE som hade glömt ta av så här och simmade helt lopp i AirPods.
Det är en väldigt konstig idrott på det sättet.
Den passar inte mig egentligen.
Jag är väldigt extrovert person och social och får energi över vad med andra.
Jag kom in på simning av en tillfällighet.
Jag spelade fotboll mycket.
Min pappa var gammal fotbollspelare.
Min mamma gammal sprinter.
Hon var Europamästare och sprang 100-200 meter och var på OS.
Så jag fick det hemifrån och började med fotboll.
Sen fick jag problem med ryggen och fick sluta med fotbollen.
Då ville jag börja med simning.
Jag hade sett det på tv och tyckte det var kul.
Sen visade jag att det var fallenhet för det.
Jag hade en rumänsk tränare, Ibi, som var otroligt bra pedagogiskt men också från gamla österblocksskolan.
Den som tränar mest volym är den som blir bäst.
Det var innan simningsrevolutionen där man började med mer markträning.
Då var det bara volym, volym, volym i vatten.
På något sätt hade jag fallenhet för det.
Jag är bra på att göra tränningskalle.
Jag kan simma tills jag går sönder.
Som tur var gör man inte resimning så mycket.
Det är ganska skonsamt för kroppen.
Det blev min sport.
Jag skulle satsa på det.
De blev bäst i världen.
Det blev jag inte bevisligen.
Men jag simmade innan skolan och efter skolan och gjorde verkligen en elitsatsning på det.
Som inte flög tyvärr.
Så det är lite kort om min idrottsbakgrund.
Varför flög det inte?
Vad är det för fel?
Om du hade fallenhet och tränat väldigt mycket.
Vart satt mitt missen?
Jag har ju den här som alla har som inte misslyckas med sin sport.
Det var ju skador.
Det var skadernas fel.
Trots att det var simning.
Jag fattar.
Jag fick problem med bihålen.
Det är ganska vanligt.
Man bader ju gift två gånger om dagen.
Jag hade tre bio-inflammationer på raken.
Jag låg in med en massa rör i näsan.
De skulle borra i skallen ett tag för att tömma bihålen.
Men det är inte anledningen.
Anledningen är att jag inte hade talangen.
Kort och gott.
Jag var för dålig.
Vad är den företagsmässiga bakgrunden?
Jag hade ingen akademisk utbildning.
Jag hade gått ut i gymnasiet.
Sen var det slut med det.
Min brorsö var på Krogen.
Jag började jobba där.
Jag har alltid haft olika entreprenörer.
Reella projekt på gång på sidan av.
Jag har haft det, men inte gjort det ordentligt.
Parallellt med att jobba i Krogen startade jag en fotbollsklubb.
Jag var engagerad i Djurgården fotboll.
Min morfar var pitchkeeper.
Vaktmästare för Djurgårdens träningsanläggning.
Jag hängde där när jag var liten.
Jag fick matchknatter och bollkalle och fylla på vattenflaskor.
Sen började jag hjälpa till på pressläktaren och pressinsläppet.
Sen var jag över 15-16 år och hade idéer om hur vi skulle utvecklas som klubb och göra det bättre.
De klappade mig på huvudet och sa att det var kul att du hade idéer, men du gick knappt på torr bakom öronen.
Sen slutade presschefen där i den vevan.
Då sökte jag jobbet och tänkte att det är klart att jag kan bli presschef i Djurgården.
Jag fick det inte, så klart.
Jag förstod inte det och tyckte att det var helt sjukt att de inte anställde mig.
Så då knöt jag den även i fickan och tänkte att jag gör det själv istället.
Då startade vi en fotbollsklubb från Division 8 i Stockholm.
Sveriges sämsta fotbollsklubb.
Vi hade en helsida i DN efter första säsongen.
Sen byggde vi upp det där.
Vi kom till Division 4, så hade vi ett bra damlag, bra ungdomslag.
Vi har några nu i juniorlandslaget som har Vasastam BK som modeklubb.
Så vi har haft lite olika entreprenöriella projekt på sidan om.
Men sen efter många omar män så satt jag med skolbänken och läste på IHM Business School.
Vi gjorde det parallellt och samtidigt med krogen på nätterna.
Vi läste ekonomi och marknadsföring och sen en master i varumärkesstrategi.
Efter det började vi jobba på olika beroer där vi hjälpte främst konsumentvarumärken med digital försäljning och marknadsföring.
Då hade vi några av de största kunderna i Sverige på den tiden.
Det var Absolut Vodka, McDonalds, Ica, SAS, Sats och flera.
Så jag hjälpte dem att bli bättre på försäljning och marknadsföring digitalt.
Vi var med i den här app-boom-edan när alla skulle ha appar till sina bolag.
Vi var 70 personer i tag och bytte appar åt Sveriges alla bolag.
Sats-appen, Avanza-appen, Ica-appen och McDonalds-appen med flera.
Läker vi bakom.
På något sätt tycker jag ändå att det är sammanfaller.
Det är mycket idrott och träning och det är ganska mycket varumärken, PR, försäljning.
Vilket känns ganska mycket som det du faktiskt sammanfattade det i nu med Måsonor.
Man tänker att ni är en e-handel men ni är egentligen ett varumärke inom.
Jag gillar det.
Det kändes som en ganska rimlig bakgrund faktiskt.
Men om vi tar första, jag bara förutsätter lite grann att folk vet vad Måsonor är.
Det är ett hudvårds-märke som gör, ni gör deosar och torr och schampor.
Nu låter det väldigt osexigt när jag säger det.
Kan du inte berätta vad ni gör?
Absolut, det är inte så sexigt.
Måsonor är ett varumärke som gör hudvårdsprodukter för dig med aktiv livsstil.
Man kan säga att Nike inom hudvård, det har varit produkter som är berikade med verksam ämnen.
Som du behöver då när du har en extra fysisk aktivitet.
Det till exempel är torr och schampor just för svettigt hår och hårbotten efter träning.
Det är ingen svalkande chowjell om du eftersvettas eller får blåssyhy.
Vi är mest kända för deodorant, clinical strength heter den.
Det är en deo med extra tryck som klarar träningspass.
Men även en svettig vardag.
Om du ska på arbetsintervju eller om du står och jobbar som kockets kök eller om du ska på en dejt.
Om du bara allmänt vill känner du extra torr i armhålen.
Kan vi inte börja där?
Det är nästan därför jag hörde av mig till dig lite grann.
Du säger alltid att du vill göra ett Nike för hudvård.
Och så har du sagt vid några tillfällen att det finns en liten öppning där eller en marknader.
Jag fattar inte det.
Dels fattar jag inte vad du menar med att ni ska göra ett Nike där.
Dels fattar jag inte.
Det finns väl deosar och torrschampor och deodoranter.
Jag tänker bara att jag är korkad.
Jag har väl aldrig googlat på torrschampor hela mitt liv.
Det är klart att det finns en massa torrschampor.
Jag förstår inte luckan och jag förstår inte Nike-referensen.
Det känns som att det är ingen som frågar dig vad du har att berätta nu.
Förklara lite för mig med Nike.
Du tänker att jag är fem.
Ja, att du är fem ställer ju till det lite.
Jag är tolv då.
Jag fattar vad dubbel dusch är.
Ja exakt.
Vi ser att du är femton då.
Vi lanserade 2020 och Andén föddes väl 2018 i mitt huvud.
Då var jag på en sim-resa och hade olika idéer på vilket bolag jag skulle starta.
Så jag åkte iväg en vecka och simma.
Sen satt jag på rummet och skrev affärsplan och gjorde en massa research.
Det var en väldigt hett då och fortfarande är vi ganska hett.
Det är hela functional foods trenden.
Det var konsumentkategori, vad ska man säga, produkter.
Du köper på hyllan, privatpersoner.
Det blir mer och mer deras funktion.
Vi har ju hela vitaminwell-gruppen i Sverige med alla deras produkter.
Det börjar med vitaminvattnet som är vatten på flaska men berikat med XYZ, lite vitaminer.
Så hela functional foods trenden lyssnar till vad som har hänt där.
Vi har ju den här knockobomen och barbells och annat.
Men det är också inom kläder.
Så ser vi hur kläder blir mer funktionella.
Om man jämför med Rocky Balboa som sprang upp för trapporna där i världens bästa film.
Han sprang runt i bomullsdress och Converse-doyer.
Det var ju high-tech då.
Om man jämför nu vad som är high-tech inom löpning.
Vi kan börja uppifrån alla skor, hur funktionen är de, hur mycket man pratar om funktionella egenskaper och olika sulor och material som andas.
Alla träningstajt som har kommit.
Uppkopplade klockor, alla digitala produkter du har till träning.
Hur mycket man mäter och kvantifierar.
Och så andra branscher som inte är så relaterade till träning.
Det kan ju vara proteinglas.
Det finns ju protein-bernaisås.
Nu eftersom det är nog för att få på träningsresor istället för att man åker och krökar.
Det finns liksom tvättmedel för träningsplagg.
Varje konsumentkategori har blivit funktionaliserad.
Funktion handlar om att det är matchat mot folk med aktivistil, folk som tränar.
Men det har inte hänt i hudvård.
Det finns inget nike inom hudvård.
99% av alla varumärken i den här kategorin som är hudvård som är allersänd till, det handlar om skönhet, om yttrest etik.
Att du blir snygg, att du blir ung, att det slätar ut.
Ja, ju nej, det handlar mycket om yttrest etik.
Och det finns ingenting kring träning.
Och då säger du, ja, men dubbeldusch och liknande.
Ja, alltså det problemet med de där varumärkena är att det är, för det första är det väldigt låg kvalitet.
Det är ju bara låg kvaliteprodukter, helt utan funktion.
Som man bara har satt någon gammal avdankad idrottsman på.
Om det är Slatan eller Foppa eller Henke Lundqvist, vem det nu kan vara.
Ja, jag undrar om det finns nått fan i Sverige du inte störde med den avdankad Henke Lundqvist, Slatan eller Foppa.
Det är möjligen nån rittare någonstans som inte blev störd.
Ja, skitsamma.
Det var bara en tro.
Ja, men exemplet är att det är låg kvalitet.
Det stora problemet med de där produkterna är att det är ingen funktion i dem.
Det är ju bara sport.
Och så är det en hockeykille som gör reklam för det.
Och så är det någon blix eller någon eld på flaskan.
Och så är det riktat sig till män.
Och true relay, det finns kvinnor som tränar också.
Så vad vi vill göra då är ta idén kring functional food, så lägger jag liksom, produkter har träningsväskan men addera ämnen då som hjälper dig och förhöjer funktionen i produkterna.
Och att vi även då riktar oss mot kvinnor.
Men säg, för jag kan ingenting om de här, alla andra produkter.
Jag använder ju den tvålen som är där jag är.
Eller vad man ska säga.
Om jag duschar hemma hos min flickvän föräldrar så använder jag ju den tvålen som står där när jag duschar.
Jag vet inte liksom.
Men deodorant använder jag i alla fall.
Och den använder jag ju under hela min tränings.
Den funkar väl?
Eller vad är det ni lägger i deodorant som ska vara intressant?
Jag har inte testat vår.
Ja men om jag tränar så gör det väl ingenting att jag svettas.
Eller är det efteråt den ska...
Vad är det ni lägger i som ska vara intressant menar du?
Det här blir lite tekniskt då.
Men det finns olika skalar på produkterna.
Vilken nivå verksam ämnen du får ha.
Och slår det verkligen i taket då blir det medicintekniskt.
Då blir det ju att du måste ha recept för att ha dem.
Men för att sälja mot konsument och i handel så kallar de sig för kosmetiska produkter.
Det är klassiskt hudbord du köper i butiken.
Så finns det olika gränsvärden.
Och det vi har gjort då, vi har skruvat upp effekten i våra produkter så ligger det precis under gränsvärdet.
Och det kan man jämföra till exempel vad NOC har gjort med koffinhalten och liknande.
Man ligger precis där man får ligga ungefär för att vara godkänd.
Ok, era verksamma ämnen har en starkare gra.
Eller ni har en högre koncentration av de verksamma ämnena.
Är det det jag ska tolka detta som?
Men den här metaforen liknande sig med Nike är även på två lager.
Det ena är produkttekniskt, att vi har högre grad av verksamma ämnen.
Men det är också varumärkesmässigt, vilken kommunikation du skickar ut och vilken position du tar i marknaden jämfört med andra.
Om vi tar till exempel, om vi jämför hudvård med skor, till exempel sneakers.
Så det finns ju knappt några motsvarande sneakers i hudvårdsbranschen.
Mycket handlar om skönhet och estetik.
Det är ju mycket då finskor.
Det är högt lackat och skinnskor som du har när du klarar upp dig.
Och det finns inte sneakers i hudvård.
Men, ja.
Men jag köper lite argumentet här, så jag går typ vidare från det.
Jag fattar när du säger det här med verknings.
Det är bara att jag aldrig reflekterat över det.
Fair enough.
Men du tog även in det här med unisex-grejen ganska snabbt här.
Du sa att om en dubbelhusha är det en snubbe om man riktar sig mot män och inte mot kvinnor.
Så ni kör fortfarande unisex-produkter?
Absolut.
Två tredjedelar av våra kunder är kvinnor och en tredjedel är män.
Så vi har hittat en balans där som är bra avväg tycker vi.
Är detta en grej?
För lite grann känner jag att detta är en idé som du tänkte i början.
Att fan, det här är en bra idé med unisex.
Jag kan argumentera för det.
Och sen är det så här, så har du inte släppt den bara?
Jag tänker försvara den här.
Är det verkligen en bra idé?
Den är både bra och generellt bara.
Måste nog.
Verksöjden och kvaliteten på idén för konceptet är kanske tre av fem.
Det är inte så att jag har uppfunnit julet här.
Men det är en idé som är god nog för att kunna flyga.
Angående unisex är jättebra när du jobbar online och katastrofalt när du jobbar offline.
Och vi har en affärsmodell där vi jobbar online primärt.
Men framförallt via återförsäljare.
Och där är det superbra.
När du startar produktsidor hos Apotea till exempel, då klickar du i det och markerar vad det är för honom, för henne.
Är den vegansk?
Är den för träning?
Är den producerad i Sverige?
Då klickar vi i alla boxar.
Motsvarande då på en hylla i butik.
Där ska det stå antingen för honom eller för henne eller om det är för träning eller om det är gjord i Sverige.
De är ofta utspridda och står på en plats i hyllan.
Vi är ett multi-genre-koncept som är utvecklat för offline.
Och där är det jättebra för att vi dyker upp egentligen i alla kategorier.
Men offline så är det svårare för att ibland vet du inte om vilken hylla de ska ställa våra produkter.
Och där framförallt unisex kan vara utmanande för att det har oftast en hylla för män som är gömd långt bak i butiken och så är det lite tråkiga gamla avdankade varumärken.
Och sen så har det kanske kropp som vi säljer produkter för.
Och det har de inte förstått att det är för kvinnor.
Det finns lite olika grejer på den här men det måste ändå vara olika funktioner eller olika känslor som efterfrågas från män och kvinnor.
Nej, det är det inte.
Är det så lätt att vi vill ha, för jag och min flickvän har ju inte direkt samma svättningsgrad när vi tränar eller vi vill inte ha samma lukt när vi tränar eller vi vill inte, alltså jag bara tänker att rent spontant så det känns bara weird.
Men jag tror att det där är lite daterat.
Jag tror att det kommer bli, man kan jämföra med olika kategorier i vår bransch och det är ju då att många varumärken som är till exempel kvinnor är väldigt vackra, insmickrande.
Det är mycket vitt, det är mycket ljusa pastellfärger, det är mycket rosa och det luktar vanilj, chasmin och helt blommiga rosiga dofter, florala dofter.
För män då, då är det liksom svart, det är blått, det är en tiger, det är en blix, det är ett vattenfall, det luktar omklädningsrum, det är muskigt.
Jag ska köpa en deo med tiger någon gång, jag gillar det.
Ja men nu drar jag upp här för att bevisa min poäng, men det ligger väldigt mycket i det och till exempel när vi gjorde den här deodoranten så gjorde vi en så stor matchundersökning och det visade sig att nästan hälften av alla män då köper, vi kollade på folk som köper Nivea deodorant och då är det hälften av alla män då köper den här vita deon som är lätt lätt rosdoft.
Just för att man vill inte ha den här stereotypa muskiga starka doften för män utan man vill ha en deo som är jobbet, som luktar lite trevligt, inte för mycket, som inte tar över.
Så jag tror att där är branschen lite daterad att det ska vara på ett visst sätt och det kan man säga om det här begår i parfym nu, där står det inte, går du tillbaka i 20-30 år då står det ju ofta för honom och för henne.
Varumärken som lanserar idag de definierar ju inte om det är för honom eller för henne.
Går vi in i träningsbranschen då så är det ju, visst då passform om det skiljer sig från kläder, men går du till skol till exempel då har du samma design på dojor för honom eller för henne.
Då har du inte olika viktplattor för honom eller för henne.
Det är samma maskiner du tränar på.
Löpanden är ju inte ergonomiskt uppbyggda för honom eller för henne.
Så att det är väl ett av de bättre vi tar.
Det är lite för enkla för man skulle kunna säga att kläderna är ju olika och man kan alltid hitta grejer som vi föra emot.
Men det jag menar är också, missar du inte en försäljningspunkt där för jag tänker till exempel att vi har olika, jag köper ju tål och shampoo och vad som är billigast på ICA.
Och det gör ju inte min flickvän.
Hon har ju en helt annan modell när hon köper grejer.
Du måste ju kunna utnyttja det eller spela på det.
Eller vill du bara såhär, ja fan jag ska gå i forefront här och hoppas på att mitt vett är det inte bra att spela in lite i.
Att man kan ta olika betalt, att man kan ha lite olika saker i, att man kan nisha sig lite.
Om jag vänder på det då, vilken doft uppskattar män?
Jag köper ju mango-passion på sådana här storflaskor.
Jag vet inte.
Är det en klassisk mansdoft då som män gillar?
Nej men skit i dofterna.
Jag bara menar att om du marknadsför mot, om jag skulle marknadsföra, jag kan ingenting av detta då.
Men om jag skulle marknadsföra mot min flickvän så hade jag ju marknadsfört kanske mer på, ja den här håller såhär länge och gör såhär.
Och så mot mig själv hade jag marknadsfört på pris.
Jag bara menar att i olika marknadsföring, känner du inte att du går förlorad den?
Eller när du säger att ni inte är ett offline-märke, är det inte fortfarande extremt mycket i offline?
Vill du inte in i alla Ica och Apotek?
Du är ju redan i den online-marknaden.
Vi är ju på Sveriges Alla Apotek och snart Nordens Alla Apotek.
Så det har vi redan.
Dagliga varuhandeln vill vi inte in på utan vi lägger oss då i fackhandeln då.
Men det är intressant liksom, om vi utgår från, säg något annat då, bortsett från doft, vad är det enda vi ska kunna särskilja på kring produkten?
Pris.
Pris till exempel, ja.
Där finns det en skillnad att män är ju vanare att betala mycket mindre för de här produkterna än kvinnor.
Men rent affärsmässigt när du utvecklar de här produkterna, de kostar ju lika mycket att göra oavsett om du marknadsför mot män eller mot kvinnor.
Och ja, det är en nackdel för oss för vi, när vi går mot unisex så blir det en utmaning att var ska vi prissätta det?
För det finns en gillande prispunkt runt 100 lappen och sen runt 200 uppåt då.
Men vi tar ju 100 lappen som exempel.
Att om en produkt är över 100 kronor för en del durante till exempel, då blir killar lite såhär, ja fan vad är det här för någonting?
Det börjar kännas lite dyrt.
Och går du under 100 lappen och pratar med kvinnor då blir du misstänksamma.
Vad är det här kvalitet egentligen?
Vad är det här för någonting?
Kommer den här vara bättre än den som kostar 250 kronor?
Så det finns ju en psykologi kring prissättning som skiljer sig just för att män och kvinnor är vana på hur marknaden är strukturerad, vilka typer av priser man är van att betala.
Och det bästa exemplet där är exempelvis shampoo.
Jag vet inte om du någon gång har mistagat, har lånat din flickvän shampoo.
Jag skulle säga att jag inte använder shampoo.
Nu ser jag inte alla min frisyr, men det är inte många millimeter på det här huvudet.
Nej, men det är väl ett klassexempel folk som råkar.
Det är inte ovanligt att kvinnor beställer shampoo för 500-600 kronor i flaskan.
Medan killar då har en van att man tar bara någonting som både funkar på huvudet och kroppen.
Och jag säger inte att detta är rätt eller fel, men är det ett principiellt stand som du har tagit för att du tror att det ska gå åt det här hållet och du tycker att det här är rätt att det ska vara unisex?
Eller tror du att detta är en grej som gör att ni sticker ut och att du får färre excuse och att det är affärsmässigt?
Varför har du valt att göra så här?
Jag ser affärsmässigt fördelar med det.
Du dubblar ju din marknad till att börja med.
Annars så diskvaliserar du för halva marknaden.
Eller du kan väl ha samma marknad, bara att du får ta fram dubbelt så många produkter.
Ja, då har du dubbat lagervärdet.
Ja, exakt, exakt.
Eller det blir lite mer komplext i alla fall.
Men absolut.
Är det en affärsmässig grej detta?
Det är inte en principiell grej.
Nej, det är affärsmässigt.
Och sen så är det inte principiellt.
Det är affärsmässigt.
Och jag tror också att det är lite daterat.
Nu överdriver ju både du och jag nu att prata om det här för er en poäng.
Men den här branschen är väldigt stereotyp.
Det är fortfarande väldigt mycket muskigt och blickstrar och dunder för arumärken för män.
Och det är väldigt mycket blommor och droppar och väldigt mycket rosa till kvinnor.
Och det där vill vi ändra på.
Både ur ett affärsmässperspektiv tror jag att det finns fördelar med det.
Och sen så tror jag att det är daterat också.
Vi vill ligga före trenden, inte bara följa marknaden.
Absolut.
Det ska bli väldigt spännande att följa och se lite hur det där går.
Antingen ligger man ju helt rätt eller så får man ju bara...
Du verkar ju också relativt flexibel i att ändra din approach beroende på vad som händer.
Men om vi säger här under 2023...
Jag kan ta ett exempel på en annan produkt.
Om vi tar just träningsrelaterade.
Om vi tar proteinpulver till exempel.
Det är i princip samma innehåll i alla proteinpulver.
Men det finns ju 40 olika smaker att välja mellan.
Och där vet inte jag om det är något produkt som ställer mer.
Bättre för kvinnor eller bättre för män.
Vad tror du?
Vi är ju lite nära den branschen.
Man brukar säga att 70% köper bara choklad och de andra köper också choklad.
Just det.
Men är det någon skillnad?
Köper andelen män och kvinnor?
Nej, det är mer förpackningsrelaterat.
Nästan alla riktade sig till män förr och nu har det kommit några, vad ska vi kalla, air quotes, kvinnliga märken som gör det lite klinare förpackningar.
De går väldigt bra.
Om man går in och kollar på till exempel protein.se så kan man kolla deras tillväxt till exempel och de riktar sig mot kvinnor.
Det är väldigt intressant att se.
Om man kollar lite mer samtida varumärken, vi tar Andreas som gäster på Tyngre.
Deras estetik, hur de utvecklar produkter.
Både förpackningsdesign och smak.
Jag har aldrig sett att det står, det här är för honom eller det här är för henne.
Och jag inbillar mig att det finns både kvinnor och män som köper deras proteinpulver.
Oavsett, eller utan att det står för honom eller henne på förpackningen.
Utgår det från smak och känslan på produkterna och vad man gillar.
Absolut, jag håller med dig.
Jag bara vill säga i så fall samma argument fast med kläder.
Det kommer alltid att finnas en förr och det finns ställen där man...
Ja, men där har du ju passform.
Okej, fair enough.
Jag hoppar vidare så att jag inte ska...
Jag tänker att jag vill inte fastna för mycket i den här break it-artikeln med kapital.
För det känns som att du har snackat igenom den några gånger, gissar jag.
Men den fick ganska mycket diskussion.
Och det du väl egentligen skrev var väl egentligen inte att man inte skulle ta in kapital utan det var väl lite mer att det blir väldigt mycket fokus på att ta in kapital blir som en vinst i sig.
Alltså att det är nästan mer fokus på att du tog in mycket kapital och det är bra snarare än vad ska kapitalet användas till.
Jag skulle gissa att det är så du skulle vilja lägga diskussionen.
Ja, för de som inte har läst kröniken så handlar det om att den heter Sluta firar riskkapital.
Det är ett kvitto på att man inte får ihop det.
Det handlar om att den här...
Vad ska man kalla det för?
Normen som råder, framförallt inom tech men många andra branscher, att folk firar när de har fått in riskkapital.
Att det skulle vara en framgång, någonting som man är glad för och bara yes, nu har vi lyckats.
Och det tycker jag är helt fel fokus.
När du bygger bolag så handlar det om att bygga värde över tid och öka aktieägarvärdet.
Du vill ju öka bolaget, det ska bli större, du kan tjäna pengar.
Gör du inte det så går det ju om kull.
Och anledningen ofta är ju att du tar in kapital för att pengarna är slut.
Hade inte pengarna varit slut så hade du inte behövt tagit in kapital.
Det är ju grundbulten i det här.
Ja, sen finns det vissa avarter där du verkligen har en jättestort tillväxt om vi kastar in ännu mer vd-bras, hur mycket snabbare kan det gå då.
Men då är det undantaget.
Det där ser man ju fladdrar förbi gång på gång, att folk är glada och de har fått in de här pengarna till den här värderingen.
Det man missar då i både mediebevakning och från många läsare som tjurar och kimmar och hejar på det där är att det som har hänt är att ägarna till bolaget har spätts ut.
Deras ägarna är ju minskade bolaget.
Så de har ju förlorat en del av sitt företag.
Och det där perspektivet pratar man aldrig om.
Det är väldigt mycket fokus på värdering, hur mycket bolaget är värt.
Men går man tillbaka och kollar på ägandet då och vad dina aktier är värda efter det här så har ju det 9 fall av 10 minskat.
Så att den här normen att fira riskkapital, att det är något positivt bolag går bra, det är ju egentligen tvärtom.
Det tar ju in pengar för att du inte får ihop det.
Jag vill bara, nu kanske det ska sägas att jag personligen har inte tagit in några pengar alls och tycker, vill inte ha det.
Men här kommer jag däremot argumentera för det.
Vi har ju ändå varit i en marknad där tillväxt har varit väldigt gynnsamt.
Och om du växer så kan du göra en mycket större exit.
Så att även om du speds ut så är det ju en positiv affär att bli mindre.
Om inte ditt mål är att ha bolaget i typ 50 år.
Men om du vill göra en resa på 5 år så är det ju väldigt positivt att fuck it, gå lite minus, ta in mycket kapital.
Och sedan göra en exit för att göra nästa resa eller dra det tillbaka eller tjäna pengar eller vad som helst.
Det är väl ändå positivt.
Ja, om du har fokus på att du ska sälja bolaget snart så finns det värde att bolaget går upp.
Men när totalvärdet på bolaget går upp, betyder det inte att aktiepriset går upp.
Dina aktier som du har, det är antalet.
Det enskilda aktievärdet, alltså värdet per aktie, behöver inte ha gått upp.
Så att du tar in mycket pengar.
Det som händer är att du trycker nya aktier som folk betalar för.
Oftast när det tillförs mycket kapital i ett företag så blir det ju att värdet, post money, när du har fått in pengarna, tar du in 10 miljoner så går definitionen av bolaget upp.
10 miljoner, för då har du 10 miljoner mer i kassen.
Och ibland så missar folk att stanna upp och tänka efter det här och räkna på det.
Men vänta här nu, om man har köpt aktier på Avanza till exempel, om ett företag gör en ny emission, det är ju en dålig sak på börsen.
De tar in pengar för att pengarna är slut.
De behöver fylla på.
Det kommer ut fler aktier på marknaden och nettot blir ju lägre.
Grundbulten med min krönika är att fokuset och normen för många unga entreprenörer har blivit att man jagar värdering, man jagar riskkapital.
Man ser bara företagande som ett sätt att tjäna pengar kortsiktigt.
Det handlar väldigt mycket om att snabbt in och snabbt ut.
Man har fokus på att sälja bolaget snarare än att få det lönsamt och växa stadigt.
Och det man gör då varje gång man tar in pengar är att man hyvlar ner sitt eget ägande.
Och jag brinner ju för entreprenörskap och vill att alla ska starta bolaget, inte alla.
Men jag vill få en sund företagsklimat i Sverige, och det har vi, men just den här hetsen till riskkapital tycker jag har blivit helt snevriden.
Och att man glömmer då bort alternativet, att du behöver inte ha så jäkla bråttom.
Du behöver inte ha ett bolag som du startar och sen säljer efter fem år, som är tankat med raketbränsle i form av riskkapital.
Det finns alla alternativ.
Det finns att du kan växa på eget kassaflöde, du kan skala ett bolag utan att du behöver spädda ut dina aktier.
Det är det som är värdet, så håll hårt i dina aktier.
Var inte så pigg på att slänga iväg dem till höger och vänster för att få in lite pengar.
Jag hörde en intervju med dig där någon frågade, nu kommer jag inte ihåg vilken det var, men någon frågade dig om du skulle göra om detta igen.
Vad var det du hade ändrat från i starten och då sa du att du hade tagit in mer kapital.
Du hade velat ha mer pengar i början där.
Och du har också tagit in kapital.
Du blev väl ändå lite glad i smyg där.
Jag sväger lite i kyrkan här.
Jag har ju tagit in kapital, men det är inte för att det var målet för något jag tyckte var skitkul och jättebra.
Min ambition har alltid varit att äga det.
Du tog emot det lite motvilligt.
Det var någon som tyckte att nu får du ta emot de här pengarna.
Nu måste du ta de här.
Anledningen till att vi behövde ta in pengar var att det inte gick med den kassen vi hade.
Jag startade bolaget av egna fickpengar.
Jag hade sparat upp 200 000 och sen gick jag till Almi och fick 200 000.
Sen gick jag till SEB och kunde få en checkredit på 200 000.
Så jag hade 600 000 som jag kunde starta bolaget med.
En batch 2 gick på nästan 300 000 och sen hade jag glömt Momsen som skulle på det hit.
Ganska snabbt hade pengarna gått åt.
Under våra första år var det kämpigt som det är med företagande.
Det som skedde sen när det smällde till och vi fick bra försäljning och stora listningar var att vi inte hade pengar.
Vi hade inget lager.
När vi fick de här stora försäljningsboosterna, när vi fick listning på Kicks och Lens.
Deras första order, att de tömde hela lagret.
Vi kunde leverera 40% av det de beställde.
När vi får en sån här boost i försäljningen när det händer saker medialt till exempel och du har ett sug och en pull på marknaden från en produkt.
Då vill du ju kunna skala upp och kunna möta det här.
Men då stod vi där helt utan lager, kunde inte sälja.
En sommaren här när vi hade vår breakthrough.
Vi vann till exempel Sveriges bästa deodorant.
Vi fick stora listningar på några Sveriges största återförsäljare.
Den sommaren hade vi inget lager.
Vi hade inga produkter.
Jag satt hela sommaren och makulera orderar.
Jag tror jag makulera nästan en miljoner orderar som vi inte kunde ta emot.
Hade du inte velat få in 10 miljoner och späda ut dig själv?
Jo, det hade varit jättebra om vi då var på ett stort lager.
Vi var underfinansierade i början.
Det ger sig efter taget.
Du köper nya produkter och sen säljer du dem och så tar det ett tag att vända lagret och till slut så har du ju fått upp ett värde i bolaget.
Ett lägevärde i lagret så du kan möta den efterfrågan.
Vi var underfinansierade i början.
Så var det.
Hade vi haft större kassan när vi började hade vi gått mycket snabbare.
Ultimat hade varit att man kunde starta med större aktiekapital eller att man hade fått in banklånen eller haft större checkkredit.
Sist på distan är riskkapital för jag vill inte sälja mina aktier.
Nu blev det så att idag äger jag 85% och Gunilla von Platen äger 15%.
Det kommer att säga att jag var med i TV4, The Apprentice.
Det är där jag spoiler, gick och vann hela tävlingen och priset är att Gunilla investerar i ens verksamhet.
När TV4 hörde av sig, det var en måndag och så kunde inspelningen börja en fredag.
Det här var pandemitider.
De hade skjutit på inspelningen nästan ett år.
Folk hade sökt programmet och stått på kö för att vara med och sen förmodligen hade någon hoppat av för att det inte gick tidsmässigt och liknande.
När jag fick förfrågan och träffade TV4 och pratade med dem så tänkte jag att jag är med några veckor och så gör jag ett stort avtryck och sen ser jag det som gratis marknadsföring.
Jag får vara med på en storsastning på TV4 med allt det innebär.
Självklart ska jag vara med.
När tävlingen utvecklade sig och jag träffade de andra deltagarna och fick känsla för Gunilla så ändrade jag fokus och tänkte att jag kan vinna.
Så gick jag för det i stället och sen hade jag tur och vann allting.
Idag är Gunilla delägare och hon gick in med kapital och lite andra garantier.
Det var lån, vilja om, finansierade om, checker dit och annat.
Hennes ägande, vi gjorde en lite abberovinkel där så hon gick in med kapital mot aktier och sen så gjorde vi lite finansierade om bolaget också.
Som gjorde att jag inte behövde släppa lika mycket aktier men att det frigjorde en massa rörelse i kapital i bolaget så att vi kunde ha större flexibilitet.
Att våga ta lite större satsningar både kring marknadsföring och försäljning kring sortiment.
Vi vågade ha mycket högre lagervärden och fler produkter i lager så att om det skulle smälla till så är vi redo.
Jag tänker två saker.
Dels tycker jag inte det ofta man hör ordet abberovinkel.
Det är inte ofta man bjuds på nu för tiden.
Dels undrar jag om du ångrar att du tog in kapital.
Nej det gör jag inte.
Gunilla kommer inte att lyssna på den här podden.
Gunilla är en otrolig tillgång.
Mycket mer än vad jag trodde.
Hon är superman som verkligen har varit en supertillgång.
Det största värdet Gunilla bidrar med är hennes kontakter, nätverk, förståelse att bygga bolag, långsiktigheten, tålmodet.
Viljan att ta risker, förståelsen för att ta ingen risk, den största risken.
Det bidrar hon med enormt värde.
Pengarna gör också en skillnad men det är inte det som är avgörande.
Om man går tillbaka då när jag drog igång det här bolaget, det var typ pengar gratis.
Det var när det kokade på börsen och alla jobbade med e-handel och riktade mot konsumenter.
Folk stod i kö för att kasta pengar efter din satsning.
Jag har ju alla de här bo...
Ja, inom träning har vi Stronger och alla träningstides och annat som exploderade på den tiden.
Jag ångrar inte Gunilla men helst av allt i en perfekt värde skulle jag lägga 100% av aktierna.
Får jag möjligheten i framtiden att köpa tillbaka dem så kommer jag vilja göra det.
Du har pratat lite om långsiktighet eller om man ska tänka långsiktigt.
Du har sagt att det här är ett företag som ska gå typ i arv till dina barn.
Det väljer man inte riktigt själv men folk fattar vad du menar i alla fall.
Kan du inte förklara...
Långsiktighet känns rätt klishigt när folk säger det.
Det blir så här att jag tänker långsiktigt.
Kan du inte förklara lite hur du tänker långsiktigt och om det finns några konkreta beslut du har tagit som är långsiktiga där du hade kunnat ta ett annat beslut om du var kortsiktig?
Det här bolaget är inte byggt för att säljas.
Det här bolaget är byggt för att bli stort och vara lönsamt och generera avkastning år efter år.
Min idé är att det här ska vara ett framtida miljardbolag.
Det finns återigen inget Nike med hudvård globalt.
Det är ingen som har tagit den positionen.
Någon kommer att göra det.
Vi är en av hästarna på banan nu och är med i racet.
Vi är en halvhäst som springer långt bak men vi är i alla fall med i racet.
Det kan gå.
Det jag menar är att det handlar om att vara smart nog att ta rätt beslut som ger effekt över tid och inte det som ger störst effekt här och nu.
Det kanske låter lite flummigt och det är inte alltid man vet det för det är ingen som kan förutsäga framtiden men man har ju ändå någon känsla av besluten.
Ett konkret exempel kan vara olika trender som råder.
Framför allt inom e-handel där det väldigt mycket snabbt handlar om inom performance marketing och annat.
Just nu är det här som gäller.
Just nu är det den här typen av formaten på annonser och koncept kring e-handelsmarketing.
Det kan handla om vilka produktstrender som kommer.
Vilken är vårens senaste produkt inom hudvård.
Om man ska...
Många bolag i min bransch letar och är på tårna och verkligen letar efter nästa trend och hakar på och verkligen hittar den.
När den väl kommer så upplever jag att man tar oproportionerliga risker.
Man kör järnet in i det här.
Man vet inte hur stor en sån trend kommer att bli.
Det kan vara antingen att det är bara någonting som flyger några veckor, en månad och har tur i ett år.
Men det är väldigt sällan det kommer produkter som blir en basprodukt som folk använder i vardagen.
Det vi gör med oss nu, vi gör produkter för träningsväskan.
Det är produkter som alla har i en träningsväska.
Det är Dorant, det är Shampoo, det är Balsam, det är en handkräm.
Det kan vara...
Nu ska vi börja med lite andra produkter.
Det är produkter som redan idag har en enormt stor marknad som alla konsumenter över hela världen använder.
Där ser vi att det...
Kan vi ta en position på de marknaderna?
Då är vi i princip garanterade en försäljning över tid.
Jämför sig vi som skulle lansera en rosmarinspray som påstår att det gör att ditt hår växer starkare.
Det har varit en boom inom hår de senaste åren.
Det är en produkt som jag ser att vi inte kommer satsa på.
För det är ingenting som jag tror kommer leva länge.
Nu pratar du lite grann om produkter, att bettet är standardiserade.
Inte standardiserade produkter, men produkter som folk skulle kunna använda 15 år i rad som inte är så trendkänsliga.
I början nämnde du en massa growth hacking-grejer, annonsformat, influencers eller liknande, som kanske mer är reklamstrategier.
Varför skulle det vara negativt att spela på att växa bolaget snabbare om man kan göra det?
Det är inte negativt.
Det finns olika vägar att gå.
Om du kör den snabba vägen kan det absolut funka.
Men du måste vara medveten om att du tar på dig väldigt hög risk.
Risken kommer med ett pris.
Ofta är det att insatsen är mycket högre och risken skruvas upp.
Om du vill ta hög risk bett gång på gång, så är du otroligt skicklig och har tur och sätter alla de där, då exploderar det.
Men ofta blir det att du kan bränna dig.
Är det att du tänker att det är hög risk att testa de här olika strategyerna?
Vad är risken?
Risken är att du...
Nu pratar vi finansierat här.
Nu pratar vi produkt.
Ska vi ta affärsmodell?
Du säljer ganska mycket wholesale.
Eller vill sälja wholesale.
Praxis idag om du ska starta ett bolag.
Det som predikas i alla poddarartiklar är att du ska köra direkt till konsument.
Det är det som är den hela gralen.
Världen är i marknad, du kan skala hur stort som helst.
Du slipper alla mellanhänder.
Marginalen är brutal för att du har ingen återförsäljare.
Allt det där stämmer.
Men det man missar är att du nackdelar med den affärsmodellen.
Du är inte bara en utvecklare och produkter, ett varumärke.
Du är också en återförsäljare.
Du har öppnat en butik.
Du är ansvarig för hela trafikanskaffningen.
Den ser man aldrig i de här exempelna när man pratar om bruttomarginaler.
Trafikanskaffningen är det dyraste du har.
Om du ska driva trafik till en e-handel, eller om du ska hitta en bra butikskoncept.
Du ska ha ett bra läge för din butik.
Det är mycket futfor.
Det nämner man aldrig.
Exempel på det kan bränna sig.
Om du har en modell med stora, tunga investeringar i trafik och en DTC-handel.
Vad skulle hända om du slog av den här annonsen?
Förmodligen ska trafik när din sajt bara stört dyka.
Försäljningen skulle gå ner.
Det sitter med ett jättestort beroende på de här mediebolagen.
Att du alltid ska ha riktigt bra annonser.
Det är en inbyggd risk i affärsmodellen.
Det är ett exempel.
Det ser du inte när du drar de här exempelna på att det är så otroligt lönsamt.
Nåt annat du missar är att du måste bygga hela organisationen för även handel.
Du måste ha hela kundtjänst.
Du måste hantera logistikbitarna med retur och annat.
Du måste ha techteam eller IT-bitar.
Allt det här också.
Du måste bygga ett team av kompetenser runt dig.
Har du inte själv och har inte mer än kunskapen in måste du anställa.
Vi gör det inte i början utan konsulter.
Det är ofta väldigt dyrt.
Performance marketing är ett jättebra exempel.
Där folk som bränner på små varumärken som startar.
Du har inte så stora mediebudgetar.
Men du har konsulter som kostar tusen spänn en timme.
Ta de pengarna och lägg dem på annonsering.
Så skulle du kunna ha mycket mer olönsamma annonser.
Men nettot hade blivit mycket större.
Det är ett exempel.
Kan jag få berätta innan?
Det är väl på samma sak.
Om man nu ska gå mot wholesale.
Är det inte bara samma risk att en kedja till exempel.
De börjar sälja, de blir din största återförsäljare i Sverige.
Plötsligt säger de att vi vill ha 10 procent högre marginal.
Så sänk det annars säljer vi ett annat varumärke istället.
Eller så bara säger de att vi ska ta in den här produkten och göra själva.
Amazon style eller Ica style eller vad som helst.
Absolut, den risken finns ju.
Eller bara en inköpare som bara tycker att Tom verkar dryg.
Han vill ju inte ha.
Inte också risker, bara andra risker.
Absolut, det är det ju.
Det är ju risker i allt företagande och alla affärsmodeller.
Men skulle dina annonser dippa 10 procent i effektivitet.
Så slår det lika mycket mot försäljningen.
Som att en återförsäljare kräver 10 procent bättre marginal.
Och det perspektivet pratar man inte om så mycket.
Det är ju otroligt volatilt att ha den här trafikkanskaffningen.
Det är det som är hantverket, det är handel.
Det är det som är det dyra och det som är det svåra.
Jag kan förklara vad vi gör för affärsmodell så folk fattar vad jag pratar om.
Jag bara förutsätter att folk har lyssnat på något avsnitt innan.
Eller vet lite vem du är.
Annars får ni gå in och lyssna på något gammalt avsnitt på Tom Fulmer.
Ja, men jag kan dra lite snabbt.
Vi är ju en hybrid, ungefär som Unisex.
Så har vi ju också en hybrid när det kommer till affärsmodell.
Så våra produkter ligger runt 100 lappen.
Vissa 79, vissa 169, med runt 100 lappen.
Det är produkter som folk har.
Tränsväskan har ganska låg intresse i produkter.
Folk tar liksom ingen omväg för att köpa de här produkterna.
Vårt snittkvitto är 241 kronor ungefär.
Någonstans 240 plus.
Det är extremt svårt att bygga en lönsam e-handel med så lönsam snittkvitto.
Det går liksom inte.
Samtidigt så vill vi inte...
Vi tror också, eller jag tror, att konsumenter idag köper mycket mer på handeln än i butik, offline.
Och det är väldigt svårt att komma in offline.
Går du in i huvudbordet och kollar så har du ju...
Går du in på Lens eller något varuhus.
Du ser de här enorma hoderna av varumärken.
Som folk betalar för att finnas.
Och det är ett sätt att stänga ut den marknaden.
Det fanns ju bara x antal hyllplatser för vissa typer av produkter.
Det är en bransch med jättehöga bruttomarginaler.
Så varumärken betalade jättemycket.
I marknadsföring och till handeln för att kunna behålla de här listningarna.
Och så fick konsumenter då välja mellan tio produkter eller tio varumärken.
Som alla vet i den här podden så har e-handeln lukrat upp det där och det blir ju ett möjlighet för långtälsortiment.
Och det är där vi kommer in.
Så att vi tror att vi vill jobba med online.
Det är där vi ska vara bäst.
Folk ska upptäcka och köpa våra produkter online.
Men vi behöver inte pusha dem och driva dem till sin egen sajt.
Utan vi vill jobba där folk gör sina inköp idag.
Och det är papotek, det är hudvård och det är träningsåterförsäljare.
Så att vår affärsmodell handlar om att vi jobbar med återförsäljare online.
Dem ska vi ju vara bäst för.
Så det handlar om nätapoteken.
Det handlar om hudvårdsåterförsäljare, träningsåterförsäljare.
Som är superstark online.
Så det är vår modell.
Det vi tjänar med det är att vi förlorar att vi har en mellanhand som ska ha en marginal.
I handen är det typ 50% i den här branschen.
Men det vi slipper då, vi slipper hela trafikanskaffningen.
Vi slipper all kundtjänst.
Vi slipper all IT-typ.
Vi slipper all logistik.
Så att vi kan ju ha en supertun organisation och ändå driva på ganska stora volymer.
Apotea kan mejla in en pall som vi klickar igenom som de skeppar från laget.
Kunde vi göra det då, DTC?
Driva in kostnader för all trafik till alla de köpen.
Klocket, packet, frakten.
Det sken iväg direkt.
Det är ju 700 order som ska hanteras.
Då får du fart och volym i vår modell.
Så har du då en...
Du har ju som grund och botten väldigt höga bruttomarginaler.
Och så har du en mellanhand däremellan.
That's it.
Så det är tjusningen med det.
Jag förstår.
Du låter skeptisk, Kirsten.
Jag vill egentligen inte ta mitt eget bolag i exempel.
Vi är väldigt olika.
Så därför blir det som att jag ibland vill ge ett exempel där det inte funkar.
Men jag vill inte heller vara löjlig.
Våra snittårdekvitton är på 5 000 och vi har en marginal på 40 %.
Det är en helt annan affär och den hade inte gått att köra via återkällare.
Så det blir så här...
Ja, det är inte riktigt det vi diskuterar.
Men man sitter ändå och tänker på sin egen business när den andra personen pratar om olika grejer.
Men det är ju valid points i din business.
Och det man väl kan sammanfatta är som att frågan någonstans handlar det om långsiktighet.
Och någonstans skulle man då kunna säga att ditt bet är......att den bästa långsiktiga vägen är att jobba via wholesale.
Och lite grann ensidå.
Men det är kanske mest för awareness och att driva in kunden.
Men att wholesale på det här sättet är det mest långsiktiga sättet för det.
Att jobba via digitala återkällare.
Jag tror att många blandar ihop e-handlare.
Och man klumpar ihop allt till en typ av massa.
Det vi är är ju ett varumärke.
Vi är liksom avsändare av en produkt.
Om vi tar Whitmerwell till exempel.
De har en liten affärsmodell som vi har.
De har ju som Bear Bells, Nocco, Whitmerwell och så.
Och det är ett varumärke som du upptäcker online.
Det är ju nusenaste åren när man börjat med annonsering på gator och torg och annat.
Men när de slog igenom, det var ju digitalt.
Det var via profiler, det var via sociala medier, det var via poddar.
Det var ju där de fick in, eller förhöjde intresset och kännedom kring varumärket.
Men det är ingen som varit inne på Nocco.se eller Whitmerwell.se eller Bear Bells.se och klickade hem produkter.
Utan då går man dit man handlar den här typen av produkter.
Och det tror jag många missar när man pratar om e-handel.
För det första blandar man ihop då e-handlare.
Det är då både varumärken som vi är och återförsäljare.
Att man klumpar ihop dem att det är samma sak.
Så i min bransch kan det vara både jag och Apotea till exempel.
Vi är ju e-handlare.
Men Apotea är en återförsäljare.
De är ju en butik.
Och vi är ju ett varumärke som förser butiken med varumärken.
Men både vi är verksamma inom e-handel.
Så där tror jag man ska börja med.
Är vi en e-handlare?
Vad menar vi?
Varumärken och återförsäljare.
Där tror jag många misstar sig.
Och sen får man vara lite nykter och se.
Är det här produkter som folk tar en omväg för att köpa?
Jag tror aldrig, liksom Nocco hade slagit som de gjort om det var begränsat till Nocco.se.
Och det var råd om i trenden då.
Det var det folk skulle göra.
Det var DTC som var grejen.
Men så har konsumentbeteendet inte ut.
Folk klickar inte hem, liksom när jag är törstig, nu ska jag gå in på nätet och klicka hem lite produkter.
Ja, folk kan klicka hem ett flak.
Och det har ju kommit nu några år senare.
Men det är ingenting som folk hade ens tänkt tanken på att göra.
Och jämfört med oss då att ja, nu behöver jag en bra deo.
Ja, jag har hört om den där.
Ja, någon kanske går in på vår site och klickar hem den.
Och det är 20% av vår försäljning idag.
Men man kanske går in på apaté.
Man behöver deo, man behöver verktabletter, man kör tankkrämen, man lägger till två till grejer och får komma upp i frifrakt.
Det är där konsumentbeteendet, det är så konsumentbeteendet ser ut.
Och det är det som är normen.
Och det tror jag är väldigt svårt att ändra på.
Och det går tillbaka då om man pratar om risk.
Hur mycket risk man kan ta i bolaget att man då väljer vad man satsar på.
Vi är långsiktiga, vi ska vara bra på några saker.
Vi ska vara bra på att ta fram ett skitbra produkter som vi ska vara bäst i världen på att sälja och marknadsföra.
Det är vad vi ska vara bra på.
Vi ska inte vara bäst och gå i klinch med apotéa om man var bäst på leveranser.
Vi ska inte gå i klinch med Lyco och ha bäst pris.
Vi ska inte gå i klinch med Biancas huvudvårdsmärke Kaya om man var bäst på att driva trafik mest lönsamt.
Alla de tre grejerna slipper vi när vi jobbar med återförsäljare.
Fördelen med offline-återförsäljare är också att, som det funkar offline, du måste betala för att vara på hyllan.
Visst, du får lite gratisförsäljning för att det står på hyllan.
Men som varumärkeförsäljare förväntar du dig att ha kampanjer löpande.
Du ska betala för att de ska ria produkterna.
Du ska betala för medlemsklubbar, du ska betala för annonser, du ska betala för hur mycket som helst.
Det är där de återförsäljare har sin största marginal.
De säljer medieutrymme.
Det har de 100 procent marginal på.
Produkterna säljer de.
Ja, det tjänar de lite pengar på, men det är deras mediepaket.
Det är där lönsamheten är för dem.
Vår modell, ja det finns nackdelar med den, men det finns också väldigt mycket fördelar.
Och lyckas du få stor försäljning på vår affärsmodell så har du liksom en otrolig lönsamhet i botten.
Och det är det vi siktar på.
Erat jobb blir på något sätt varumärkesbyggandet och att se till att produkter kommer och finns, att de är bra och sånt där.
Men du har också nämnt att du är anti...
Låter som du bara är antiallting.
Kul kille, han är emot allting.
Du har nämnt att du är lite anti-influencer-grej, men att du inte tror på den så där jättestarkt.
Jag bara tänker på Nike.
Nike, kanske man säger Nike.
Det är ju typ hela deras grej är ju influencers.
Och det är ju det som har byggt deras bolag.
Ganska mycket är ju att vi får tro att vi är rationella och sånt där, men det är ju emotionellt kopplat.
Hur tänker du att du bygger ditt varumärke utan...
Om det inte är du själv som säljer, utan det är någon annan som säljer och du ska inte använda andra människor för att göra det.
Hur bygger du varumärke?
Du är säkert jättetrevlig, men är det du som ska vara huvudperson i Finland?
Vi kan börja med Nike då.
Hade Nike lanserat idag från scratch med sin befintlig affärsmodell så hade det inte flugit.
Varje fas som bolaget är inne i så måste du också justera och ändra affärsmodellen för att den ska lira med samtiden och storleken på bolaget.
Det tror jag många gör är att man kollar på de som är bäst i branschen.
Nu är Nike ett av världens största och mest välkända varumärken.
Folk kollar på Apple eller Tesla eller vilken bransch som helst.
Där tror jag att man ganska snabbt missar att vi inte är den volymen, vi är inte så stora.
Vi måste ha en affärsmodell som funkar här och nu för oss i uppstartsfas.
Då är det väldigt många som springer till influensmarketing och tror att det är den heliga gralen.
Om vi startar ett varumärke som bygger på att influenser ska älska oss och sen är det fredag eller veckan, sen är det bara party.
Det finns jättemånga bolag som startar med den tron.
Det är dagens playbook, det är så det funkar.
Jag kan sätta min högra hand på att 10 av 10 av de som har den modellen kommer misslyckas.
Det finns några exempel som har lyckats, men det är också i min bransch Kaya, till exempel Kaya Cosmetics.
Det är ju startat av Bianca Grosso.
Det är en TV-kändis och en generation.
Det är fyra generationer officiella personer och mediepersonligheter.
Hade hon varit en tjej som bara var en influencer, det finns jättemånga sådana, som startar ett bolag.
Det funkar ju inte.
Det är många som startar huvudvårdsvarumärken, influencers.
Hade då influencer marketing varit grejen och det är den hela graden och det är det som funkar, varför flyger inte alla influencervarumärken?
Det borde de göra om influencer marketing är det mest effektiva och bästa sättet att driva trafik och bygga varumärken.
Men det gör de ju inte.
Fair enough, vi använder inte influencers.
Men jag vill ändå förstå vad ni ska göra då.
Ni ser ju nytten i Tome, men han får ta ett tugge med och dricka lite vatten och förbereda sig.
För nu kommer en monolog här på åtta minuter där han hyvlar av mig.
Ja, det var faktiskt en snus.
Inget tugga med att ta satser.
Och här har vi varit skitdåliga.
Det är en sak som vi har misslyckats med.
Vi har varit dåliga på marknadsföringen av våra produkter.
Vi har varit superbra på försäljning, införsäljningen, men vi har misslyckats med att bygga kännedom kring varumärket och bygga brandkänslan kring varumärket.
Det har vi varit dåliga på.
Det är en ting som är nummer ett på min lista framåt här, vad vi behöver utveckla och bli bättre på.
Influencer marketing, ja det finns relevans i det.
Hur medielandskapet ser ut, och ja det borde vara en del av mixen i alla moderna marknadsplaner.
Men det ska inte vara den enda kanalen du jobbar med.
Och det ska inte stå för 80% av dina medieinsatser, utan det måste vara en del, en mix i ett större sammanhang.
Där du inte står och faller med en mascot som säger att det här varumärket är det coolaste och de här produkterna är bäst.
För att sedan månaden efter stå och pusha en annan, en konkurrent i samma bransch och säga nu är de här bäst, nu är de här de bästa som gäller.
Vänta, nej, jag vill tillbaka.
Har du några tankar kring hur ni ska bli bättre på att bygga varumärket framöver?
Man får ju också sätta det lite i perspektiv.
Du säger ju det själv att det är klart att du inte alla svarer här.
Men ni har ju också precis varit i, vad blir ni, ni blir fyra år nu, fem år.
Så då jobbar man ju på ett visst sätt såklart.
Så fair enough, folk får ha lite slack här så att inte folk är driga liksom.
Men har du några tankar på att om tre till fem år då önskar jag att jag kunde jobba på det här sättet för att bygga varumärket?
Vad är din heliga gra, vad tror du funkar?
Men jag tror det vi vill, och tror alla varumärkesägare, alla företag, de vill ju ha produkter som konsumenten älskar och vill köpa av.
Och tycka att få en pull av marknaden, att man inte behöver trycka ut produkter utan att marknaden vill köpa av den.
Och det är ju då varumärket som ger den här dragkraften, varför folk vill köpa det.
Om du går tillbaka till Nike igen, det finns en andel till att man köper Nike-strumpor för 100 spänn dyrare än bomullstrumpor på Stadium, som är deras egna varumärke.
Det är ju den mangin alla vill åt.
Och det är ju det som är värdet ett bolag sedan över tid, den IP-bolaget, varumärket.
Nike kan ju i princip lansera vilken produkt som helst nu i bassortiment, och den kommer kunna ligga mycket högre än motsvarande produkt utan varumärke.
Men det vi vill göra, vi gjorde en satsning förra året på att ta in en marknadschef i bolaget, och för det är vårt nästa steg.
Jag behöver ta in någon som kan marknadsföring bättre än mig, som kan äga det och framförallt då bygga varumärke, strategisk kommunikation över tid.
Och det är vi fortfarande på jakt efter.
Vi gjorde en satsning förra året där vi gick ut i annonsering, jag tror vi fick 400 sökande till tjänsten.
Och vi hittade en superbra person som var kanon, liksom den bästa av alla som sökte, och verkligen fem av fem som person.
Men det funkade inte.
Jag tror att det var för tidigt för oss att hinna den personen.
Jag tror också att det kanske var lite tidigt för henne i karriären.
Och det var ju så att vi hade det vi behövde, och det vi verkligen skulle behöva, det var någon som sitter med mer erfarenhet och mer kompetens.
Men det hade vi inte råd med.
Det följde tillbaka till mig att jag var lite snabb på att plocka in någon, för vi behöver lite mer sen i år som kostar lite mer.
Så vi hade ganska kämpigt fjolår där vi gjorde första gången en förlust i bolagets historia.
Så den satsningen kostade oss en miljon ungefär, och då var det då löner i en del, men framförallt är det satsningar som inte flög kring marknadsföring.
Och just marknadsföring är väldigt snabbt.
Det kan springa iväg om du inte återigen där tillbaka till tio procents diff med en återförsäljare.
Har annonser som där effektiviteten dippar 30-40 procent, då går det jäkligt fort att pengarna tar slut.
Så du genererar inte försäljning.
Så planen framåt är att plocka in kompetens i bolaget som är duktig på det här.
Och som blir en rad av partner till mig och bygger bolaget och varumärket framåt.
Är det svaret på frågan?
Ja, absolut.
Jag tycker dock att ni har varit ganska bra på PR eller att synas.
Det är som du säger.
Men ni har ju framförallt varit jävligt bra på införsäljning.
Ni finns ju på väldigt, väldigt många ställen.
Med tanke på storlek och med tanke på hur tidigt det är.
Ni var ju ganska tidigt inne på väldigt många ställen.
Och allt från apotekskedjor till gymgrossisten.
Och ni gjorde någon grej nu med gymgrossisten där man ska betala i sweat equity.
Det är typ att träna så får du det här.
Och det är också lite såhär, när vi omsätter dem 1,8 miljarder eller någonting och ni omsätter 3-4.
Jag bara hittar på honom.
Men under tio.
Vi är ju små.
Ja, men varför ska de ta in er som...
Jag säger bara gamla bokslag.
Det är ju för att ni har lyckats sälja in er på något bra sätt.
Och du syns ganska mycket.
Så jag tycker ändå att ni får in en del PR där.
Det är inte så att du vill ha den rollen och jobba PR stenhårt.
Min roll i...
När jag startade bolaget så var jag supertydlig med och bestämd att jag ska inte synas på något sätt i kommunikationen.
Jävligt bra det här.
Ja, men det var verkligen...
Det ska kännas stort, det ska kännas mastigt och det ska kännas som ett stort barmärke som kommer här.
För det ska vara legitimt på alla marknader och kännas superprossigt och krispigt och kan kännas bombastiskt.
Och det lyckades för mig ganska bra.
Vi fick många listningar och handeln såg det här och tyckte det var spännande.
Men vi sålde ingenting.
Det var helt ointressant för konsument.
Och då hade vi ändå några av världens största konglomerat i vår bransch hörde av oss, ville veta vilka som låg bakom den här satsningen.
Vilka spelarna är det här?
Vad har ni för plan framåt?
Kan vi ha en strategisk diskussion hur vi ser på marknader?
Alltså då satte jag en källare på Gärdet, hyrde in mig i ett rum, jag satt i en garderob liksom.
Med en paltvål som jag satt på.
Det var mitt lager.
Och jag tänkte det här går skitbra.
Vilken rivstart vi har fått.
Men det sålde inte för det var helt ointressant för konsumenter, privatpersoner som ska handla.
Så vi fick väldigt bra listningar men produkterna bara stod och dammat på hyllan.
När det tog fart för oss, det var när jag var med i podden Tvålkungen som finns på Spotify som verkligen tog fart.
Och det handlar om en podd där man då ska, hur är det att starta bolag på riktigt?
Och jag skulle vara med i ett avsnitt, det skulle vara en serie med en säsong då med massa olika episoder.
Jag skulle vara ett episode.
Men de tyckte det var så bizarrt när de träffade mig.
Jag satt i den här källan och pratade om det miljardbolaget.
Och jag tror att de inte fick tag så många andra varumärken så det blev ja då, hela säsongen.
Så föräldrar de mig första året då hur jag byggde upp det här.
Och allt ifrån att jag liksom Momsen ska in, då får jag sälja soffan här hemma för att jag hade inte pengarna.
Fick jag köpa tillbaka en två veckor.
Mina barn undrade såhär, var det soffan?
Fick jag ljuga ihop?
Ja, vi kommer en ny här om två veckor.
Så det var ju skitjobbigt.
Jag gick i två år utan lön och det var verkligen skitkämpigt.
Som jag sa innan, vi var underfinansierade.
Men jag slät verkligen som en hund där för att få det funka.
Och jag förstod inte varför det inte tar fart.
Vi har ju alla de återförsäljningarna, det ser ju skitbra ut.
Men det var helt ointressant.
Och när podden slog till och kom, eller när podden släppte sedan och blev populär, det var då försäljningen tog fart.
Det var då det smällde till.
Vad spännande.
Och det förstod jag inte.
För här sitter jag och pratar om hur jag ska, idén kring varumärken, visionen och vad jag försöker bygga och min hybris.
Det var ju det som var innehållet i podden.
Men det kunde folk relatera till.
Det tyckte folk var intressant och roligt.
Och sen blev det ringa på vattnet att podden gjorde att det var med i tv-programmet och sen så var det lite andra poddar som hörde av sig.
Och sen så, ja, jag tycker det är kul att debattera.
Sen skrev det debattartiklar, lite krönor.
Det där tog fart.
Och nu är det motan som driver då, eller en av de drivkrafterna som driver varumärket framåt.
Och när det verkligen slog till, det var ju när folk kunde relatera till mig och min vision och hur jag kämpade.
Och de här mjuka, emotionella värdena, det tyckte folk var kul.
Och det var då, på lättnästa tid, att det behövs någon person, någon individ, att relatera till det varumärket.
Någon att heja på, någon att ha kött och blod.
Och styrkans för oss nu är att vi är små.
Det är inte att vi är stora, som jag försökte i sen sätta att vi var en storspelare.
Vi gillar handen.
Men konsumenterna gillar att vi är små.
De gillar att vi är andel dog varumärk.
Och att vi går in i en bransch som är stenhård konkurrens.
Och de vet att det är någon person där bakom som säljer soffan.
För att momsen ska in en månad och verkligen kör järnet.
Så nu är det ju mer, jag tycker det är, hur jag motiverar mig nu i olika sammanhang, det är att, hade jag haft en annan vd på det här bolaget.
Och den hade sagt att, ja, men jag har fått frågan om att vara med nu i Postnord.
När de släpper e-handelsrapporten varje år.
Vi vill att, ja, jag får frågan varje år vad man är i studien och kommenterar den och debatterar.
Hade den sagt nej, jag vill inte, för att jag tycker inte det är så kul.
Då hade jag sagt, ja, men det är din förbannande plikt som vd.
Det är klart att du ska vara det, ut och snacka, ut och babbla på.
Så det är så jag motiverar mig nu, att okej, det ingår i jobbet.
Jag får spela den här rollen då som maskott för bolaget.
Influencer, skulle jag säga.
Den ofrivilliga influensen.
Fan, det hade varit ett bra pådrag.
Jag gillar det som titel.
Ja, men jag ska fundera på det, ofrivilliga influensen.
Den ofrivilliga influensen, ja, där har du.
Ja, men jag, absolut, jag köper det och jag funkar ju själv så för bolaget.
Man blir lite medial i sig.
Du har ändå sagt ganska många uttalanden som, och vi har liksom gått igenom hälften, men jag ser lite hur tiden går igenom.
Så om folk gillar detta får ni gärna säga till, för jag hade kunnat prata om detta i tre timmar till.
Men skulle du säga att du har fått en del hardcore fans som verkligen hejar på dig, men har du också fått en del människor som du märker verkligen stör sig på dig?
Ja, ja, till bägge.
Hardcore fans.
När Tvålkuggen kom, jag fick ju sådana här långa mail där någon pappa berättade.
Han ba, ja, vi är uppe i fjällen med barnen.
Jag spelade hela säsongen på vägen upp och sen plöjde hela säsongen på vägen ner.
Bara för att jag ville att familjen skulle höra det här och förstå innebörden av att kämpa och ville bygga någonting från botten.
Man jobbar hårt och får ingenting gratis.
Men när man får sånt så undrar man, fan, är det liksom ett skämt?
Det här är ingenting som...
Det var ju inte meningen att det skulle vara så.
Sen är det ju många som tycker olika än mig och som kanske till och med stör sig upp mina åsikter, men det är okej.
Vi behöver inte tycka lika om allting.
Och jag tycker det är härligt med högt i tak.
Jag ser inte det här som någon profet och vet allting om allting.
Men jag tycker att vissa ämnen ibland måste man kunna diskutera.
Vissa sanningar måste man kunna ifrågasätta.
Jag tror att det är sunt.
Jag tror att också när man debatterar, sanningen är ju någonstans mitt emellan.
Det är ju inte allting svart eller vitt.
Det är alltid någon typ av gråskala.
Men just framförallt i Sverige nu med det klimatet, det är väldigt svart eller vitt.
Det är väldigt normdrivet.
Så här är det.
Det är så här du ska göra.
Jag tror många entreprenörer, eller i alla fall unga entreprenörer, tidiga entreprenörer läser det här och tänker och tror att okej, gör jag så här enligt den här checklisten som jag läst om i alla artiklar, alla poddar, då kommer bolaget flyga.
Och det finns säkert hur många som helst som gör då i en konstens alla regler.
Och så märker de att det inte flyger.
Och så undrar de, vad är det som händer?
Och landar de i slutsatsen, det är jag som är värdelös, det är jag som är dålig.
Och så slutar de.
Och det tror jag är väldigt tråkigt och vi går miste om väldigt många bra företag i landet på grund av det.
Absolut.
Tom, fan vilket roligt avsnitt.
Spretigt.
Jag är väldigt spretigt, men då ska folk ändå veta att det kunde ha varit ännu mer spretigt för att jag hade ett femtontal punkter som jag ville prata om och jag tror att jag pratade om sex av dem.
Ja, men jag är nog delaktig där, att jag babblar på.
Ja, men jag gillar det.
Så jag får säga ett stort tack för att du var med och för att du delade och att du bara körde på.
Jag uppskattar er som fan.
Ja, tack själv.
Det är superkul att du hörde av dig och jag lyssnar på flera avsnitt på den.
Jag tycker det är kanonpåd.
Och kul att den här branschen också får lite personerna bakom det också inom träning får lite strålkastig ljus.
Låt mina två ungar komma hem, det är därför jag sprang upp förut.
Jag är färdig om fem minuter.
Vi får berätta för mamma vad ni ska göra.